hey guys Pete here this will be my
better call Saul season 5 recap I'm
gonna go through the whole thing so this
is gonna be a long video and it will
definitely contain spoilers if you
haven't watched season 5 yet I did recap
and review videos for each episode as
they aired so I would recommend those
videos if you're watching along or if
you want more details on the events of
season 5 Before we jump into season 5 we
should talk about where the characters
were at the end of season for the death
of Jimmy's brother Chuck in the
aftermath of that hungover Jimmy and Kim
side of the story throughout season for
Jimmy's license to practice law was
suspended so he had to complete a PPD
program to get it back
that meant community service and a job
but it also meant that he had a lot of
free time the main thing that season 4
showed us in regard to Jimmy is that he
is a damaged man he seems incapable of
processing his loss which makes sense
since his relationship with his brother
was super complicated and he starts
acting out as a result slip and Jimmy
reimburses and his idea of selling drop
phones to criminals sets the stage for
the Saul Goodman persona to develop
Howard is falling apart in season 4 and
Jimmy is fine with letting him think
that he's responsible for Chuck's death
Jimmy and Kim drift apart as she starts
to focus on pro bono work to help her
find balance in her career and he's out
there slinging cellphones they come back
together through some mutual scamming
and eventually Kim helps Jimmy get
reinstated lalo Salamanca arrives to
help nacho run things and makes it his
business to be a pain in Gus's ass this
leads to Mike having to kill Verner
who'd he'd become friends with Jean had
an intense moment in his flash-forward
he was admitted to the hospital after
fainting at Cinnabon and got spooked on
the taxi ride home this is where we'll
transition to the season 5 recap since
the Jean teaser picks up right where
this left off in fact season 5 starts
with the longest Jean teaser we've seen
so far and as mentioned it picks up
right where the one from season 4 left
off
mr. taco Vick is running scared after he
thought a taxi driver with an
Albuquerque air freshener recognized him
when he returns home we see that he has
the substantial stash of diamonds which
looked to be enough for him to get out
of town
and start over if he needs to we watched
him playing it safe drive me across the
border while watching a police scanner
after some paranoid time at home he goes
back to work and gets approached by that
cab driver who we find out his name Jeff
Jean then calls Edie disappear for
another extraction but changes his mind
while he's still on the phone talking to
him he tells Edie I'll fix it myself
and that's where we leave him until the
season 6 opening teaser comes around the
Jimmy McGill timeline also picks up
right where we left things at the
courthouse at the end of season 4
Jimmy changes his name so that he can
practice law under Saul Goodman and Kim
doesn't like the idea later at their
apartment Kim lays things out after she
gives Jimmy the JMM bag in the world's
second best lawyer mode
she says she's worried that Jimmy is
selling himself short she's concerned
that he worked so hard to become a
lawyer and this will all just backfire
he acknowledges her unease at one point
by saying this is why this works I go
too far and you pull me back but they're
not exactly on the same page Kim's not
getting why he thinks this is the best
direction for his career but it's clear
that he's gonna go ahead anyway we see
that they're out of sync with each other
throughout the first few episodes of the
season in a telling exchange he tells
her that he can't go back to being Jimmy
McGill
he says Jimmy McGill the lawyer is
always going to be Chuck's loser brother
the name is burned this is how I move
forward and I like it Jimmy believes
that becoming Saul is his best chance at
success and we see him working hard to
get things going
Jimmy has his phone giveaway laying out
his pitch for his legal services to
everyone who comes in to get one he's in
classic Saul Goodman mode he reverses
course on a promise he made to Kim
earlier offering 50% off for nonviolent
felonies when he runs out of funds he
ends up getting some clients and he
falls right into this new role of being
a criminal lawyer on the other side of
things we see a meeting go down with
Juan bolsa Gus and Lalo at the chicken
farm
Gus uses some stepped-on drugs that he
had nacho plant to set up a cover story
for the Verner incident he shows them a
new chicken chiller facility he's
building where Lalo gets to see Mike
working for him Lalo says that explains
everything and we know he isn't buying
it
bolsa tells the two men that they have
to come
exist when they're alone together Lalo
brings up Santiago and that makes us
wonder if we're gonna learn more about
Gus's backstory in Chile later Lalo goes
to visit Hector at his assisted living
facility his uncle tells him to mess
with Gus's money if he wants to weaken
his position what's the cartel Lalo gets
an idea on how to do this later when
Domingo is arrested outside of one of
their stash houses Mike starts out in a
bad place in the beginning of season
five he sends the Germans home and we
can tell that he's struggling after
killing Werner he punches Kai in the
face when he says that it had to be done
but let's Caspar slide when he says that
Verner was worth more than 50 of you
referring to Mike Mike tries to tell Gus
he's done working for him but Gus
doesn't go along with it he tells him
that he will still be paid as a retainer
and Mike tries to reject that he spends
the beginning of the season in a funk
that takes him to dark places he blows
up on Kayleigh after Stacey calls him up
to babysit at the last minute she
started talking about Matty and he ended
up screaming at her this becomes a wedge
between him and his family because
Stacey knows something's going on and
obviously he can't come clean about what
it is he drinks heavily and gets into a
couple of fights with a group of local
tough guys who try to shake him down as
he walks home he wins the first in
impressive fashion but they overpower
him the next time he gets stabbed and
loses consciousness and when he wakes up
he finds himself in Mexico the spot
nacho finds himself at the beginning of
season 5 isn't much better than Mike's
he's pulled out of bed by Tyrus and
Viktor and taken to where his dad's
hanging out as a threat Gus tells him he
needs to know what Lala was planning and
tells him to find a way to gain his
confidence at one point nacho cooks up a
scheme to have someone by his father's
shop off of him so that he can get him
to run away with him his dad figures out
that he's behind it and tells him if he
wants to run go ahead and run but that
he'll never leave in the midst of Jimmy
working his magic around the courthouse
he runs into Howard Hamlin Howard looks
to have bounced back from the low point
we saw him in during the last season he
asked Jimmy to have lunch with him and
when they finally do he offers him a job
at HHM
to his credit howard apologizes for his
past behavior and the offer is sincere
he tells Jimmy to think about it and
leaves it there we see that the anger is
still under the surface for Jimmy though
and the hug goodbye in Howard's
namaste license plate don't sit well
with him Jimmy has no intention of
working for HHM but he strings Howard
along saying he's thinking about it
whenever it comes up Jimmy also sets out
to hurt Howard through a couple of
stunts first he sneaks up to his gate at
night and throws bowling balls over it
damaging his car later he sends a couple
of prostitutes he was defending to
interrupt a business lunch
Howard was having with Cliff from Davis
and main to publicly humiliate him for
all intents and purposes Kim's careers
going great she still got Mesa Verde
which in the words of rich Schweikart
keeps the lights on and she feels like
she's making a difference with her pro
bono work things go sideways when she
gets called away from said pro bono work
and finds herself at odds with mr. Acker
Acker is the lone holdout refusing to
leave his home so that Mesa Verde can
move forward with plans to build a call
center
when Kim can't fix this problem herself
she cooks up a plan that involves Jimmy
acting as a KERS lawyer
Jimmy wins Acker over and one of the
funniest scenes of the season and holds
the construction up through a series of
different interventions while Kim tries
to change Mesa verities Minds things
start to get crazy as this subplot
covers several episodes no matter how
easy they make it for him Kevin won't
back down to Acker when that becomes
clear Jimmy suggests they give up and
it's Kim who wants to keep going they
try to get dirt on Kevin who turns out
to be clean but Kim finds an angle to
play when looking at photos they got
from a PI that they hired eventually
though Kim decides to call things off
rather than risking her position at
Schweikart and Cokely
Jimmy reluctantly agrees in the moment
but later he has second thoughts things
are mostly going Saul's way in his new
practice until nacho picks him up off
the street outside the courthouse he
takes him to meet Lolo who needs a
lawyer to help him with his plan to
[ __ ] Gus's operation he hires Jimmy
to feed information to krazy-8 in jail
while acting as his lawyer this leads to
Hank and Gomi from the DEA making an
appearance
it means Jimmy is now working for the
cartel I should mention that Jimmy isn't
exactly enthusiastic about the
development not surprisingly he finds
himself in way over his head later but
yeah
to give the credit to Lalo for getting
him involved in the first place as
things develop we realized that Lalo and
Jimmy have a lot in common in their
ability to talk people into doing what
they want things escalate between Gus
and Lalo acting on the tip from krazy-8
the DEA makes a move on some augustus
debt drops where dealers kick their
earnings upstairs nacho was able to gain
Lala's confidence in a dramatic gesture
during the stash house raid so he's
feeding Gus information the whole time
Gus has to let the DEA grab the money
and a few of his low-level dealers in
order to protect his Inside Man nacho
Gus was responsible for Mike waking up
in Mexico and he visits him there to try
to win him over he tells them that he's
in a war and needs a soldier he says
he's different from the Salamanca's and
then he thinks mike understands revenge
he doesn't claim to be a good person and
it's interesting that Mike decides to
work for him it's more like mike is
accepting that this is what he's good at
doing rather than him getting on board
with an alliance with Gus later Mike
will tell Stacey that he's decided to
play the cards he's been dealt he says
this right after he's able to have a
conversation with her about Matty which
tells us that he's in a better place and
we see that he's made peace with being a
button man for Gus as a means to an end
of taking care of his family in his new
role he goes after Lalo and is able to
get him arrested for the travel wire
murder while he's working on that he
becomes the point of contact for nacho
in their discussions Mike learns that
nachos father who is not in the game is
being threatened to keep him in line
we know mike has an issue with innocent
people getting caught up in cartel
violence and so later he tries to go to
bat for nacho with Gus without success
heading into the back half of the season
Kim and Jimmy are working together which
always seems to have a positive effect
on their love life after some early
turbulence around Jimmy suggesting a
scam on one of her pro bono clients
things come back around for our favorite
couple we watched this unfold through
some nice scenes on the balcony together
and as Kim doesn't impression a Kevin
that turns Jimmy on things take a turn
when Jimmy shows up and surprises
everyone including Kim by moving ahead
with their plan when she was expecting
him to settle
the Acker case it's glorious to watch it
unfold but the whole time we're worried
about how this decision will affect Kim
Schweikart and Cokely try to strategize
how to hit back but Kevin takes matters
into his own hands calling Jimmy on the
phone they meet in the parking garage to
discuss the terms Jimmy gets everything
he wants and Kim has plausible
deniability since she didn't know what
he was up to later Kim comes home pissed
at Jimmy for making her the sucker in
the scam he tries to talk her down but
she unloads on him
she says you turned you and me versus
the bank into you versus me she says
that she can't trust him it seems like
she's had enough and is really ready to
leave but as she's talking she comes up
with a plan she shocks everyone by
suggesting that they get married instead
the next day Jimmy and Kim discussed the
terms of their new full disclosure
honesty pact before the wedding
Huell arrives and they start the
paperwork for the marriage license and
they both expressed that they're doing
this for legal reasons but during the
ceremony we see they have real affection
for each other and it's more than just a
legal arrangement and just like that Kim
becomes Jimmy's third wife after the
wedding Jimmy meets with Lalo and the
interview room at the jail Paula tells
him he doesn't want to make a deal and
that he wants bail he throws up do you
want to be a friend of the cartel out
there to try to get Jimmy on board at
this point in the season there's a lot
going on Lalo turns out to be just as
much of a problem in jail as he was on
the outside and he tossed nacho with
burning down one of Gus's restaurants
Gus meets with Lydia and Peter Schuler
from magical electro-motive because
Schuler's worried about their business
arrangement Gus has to calm them down
and in that we learned that they know
each other from chill a with Mike's help
Jimmy is able to get Lalo bail they
hired people to pretend to be Lalo's
family and the family of the travel wire
victim is in the courtroom as well Jimmy
is thrown off when he sees them and we
can see that it makes things difficult
for him but he still pulls it off the
judge grants Lalo a seven million dollar
cash bond he says he can get that but
he's gonna need Jimmy to pick it up for
him out in the hall we see Jimmy
watching Fred's family Howard approaches
him he calls him out about the car and
the prostitutes he says Jimmy I'm sorry
you're in pain and that sets Jimmy off
he launches into a tirade that concludes
with him saying lightning bolts shoot
from my fingertips because of their new
honesty policy Jimmy tells Kim he's
going to pick up the bail money she
doesn't like it and she doesn't want him
to go and basically the only thing he
can tell her is that it won't be a
problem of course things don't go as
planned he gets ambushed by a group of
bandits that we later learn Juan bolsa
hired in an effort to protect Gus's
business stopping Jimmy would keep Lalo
in jail where he would be less of a
problem in boss's eyes he doesn't know
that Gus is trying to get him out so
he'll go back to Mexico where he can try
to assassinate him Mike was able to save
Jimmy from being killed but they end up
stranded in the desert when Jimmy's
esteem dies on them they take a brutal
hike through the desert but managed to
get to the money to the court and get
Lalo out of jail there's no cell
reception on their journey so Kim has
left to worry about why Jimmy didn't
make it home in desperation she goes to
see Lalo in jail which puts her on his
radar and he knows he can use that to
his advantage Mike also learns that
Jimmy told Kim where he was going and he
says now she's in the game he's right of
course but Jimmy doesn't want to believe
it at whom Kim takes care of Jimmy who
doesn't tell her the truth about what
happened when he has the chance he asked
her about meeting with Lalo and then
tells her I'm in the game you're not in
the game he makes her promise to never
meet with Lalo again and she agrees Kim
asked if it was all worth it and he
tells her to go look inside his bag he
wanted her to see the hundred thousand
dollars he made which she does but she
also sees the mug with the bullet hole
in it she doesn't tell him that she saw
it yet and she just lets him continue to
lie
Jimmy struggles with PSD for the rest of
the season and she does her best to be
there for him at the close of the 9th
episode Kim arrives home to find Jimmy
in bed she tells him that she quit her
job and he gets upset saying that she's
making a bad decision
they argue with her making her case
until there's a knock at the door
it's Lalo and he wants answers it turns
out that he turned around before heading
to Mexico because he found the esteem
and now thinks Jimmy is lying to him
about what happened he keeps making him
repeat his story which is incredibly
intense Jimmy isn't his normal self
after the
desert and he's terribly worried about
Kim he's not able to talk himself out of
the situation and almost breaks when
Lalo tells him he saw the bullet holes
in the car Kim actually has to step in
and she rises to the occasion she's able
to turn things around and Lalo
eventually leaves he tells nacho the
plans changed and they're both going to
Mexico Mike who had been listening
through Jimmy's phone and watching
through his rifle scope is able to stand
down Lalo and nacho retreat to his
Hacienda and after a trip to Donal
audios we see Gus's assassination
attempt takes shape in the end both Lalo
and nacho make it out alive
nacho opened the gate for the assassins
after creating a diversion in the
kitchen he makes it outside the compound
but we don't know how far he made it
from there
Lalo hatches a plan on the fly to use
his escape tunnel as a trap for the
attackers instead of running away when
he makes it outside he returns to the
house and is able to dispatch them he
uses the last living assassin to make a
call to his bosses to tell him that the
job is done he notices the decanter that
nacho brought out telling us that he
suspects he was involved he sees his
favorite cook murdered in the driveway
as he walks away from the house with
murderous rage and thoughts of revenge
written all over his face while this is
all going down Jimmy and Kim are holed
up at a hotel they decided to leave the
apartment after Lalo took off and Jimmy
came clean about what happened in the
desert they stay there for most of the
finale other than a short trip to Mike's
for Jimmy where he learned that Lala was
supposed to be killed and a trip to the
courthouse where Kim ran into Howard
these two encounters shape the setup
from the next season with Jimmy thinking
they're safe now because Lala will be
taken out of the picture he decides that
maybe it would be best if they separated
to keep him away from the cartel on
hearing this she doubles down on the
relationship and tells Jimmy about her
conversation with Howard over dinner the
way Howard came at her set Kim off and
they start talking about continuing to
mess with him it starts out innocently
enough but as the night goes on Kim
hatches a serious plan she tells Jimmy
that they could set up Howard for
something that would get him in enough
trouble that the other interested
parties would want to settle the
Sandpiper class-action suit Jimmy and
Kim would stand to pick up two million
dollars if that happen
and Kim says she would open a pro bono
office with it to provide people with
limited means the same kind of
representation that millionaires get
Jimmy tries to put on the brake saying
that Kim would not be okay with this if
she ruined Howard's career because for
all his shortcomings Howard doesn't
deserve something like that
Kim doubles down again responding to
Jimmy wouldn't I when he says she
wouldn't be okay with it
and she walks away from the bed turning
with finger guns shooting in Jimmy's
direction Jimmy doesn't look like he's
completely on board with the plan and
he's not sure what to make out of what
just happened with Kim it leaves us to
wonder if they'll really go through with
the next season and if Kim will be the
one Breaking Bad before all is said and
done and with that I will leave it there
check out my season 5 ending explain
video for more about the ending if you
want to dig in deeper and please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already if you're watching this right
after season 5 ended you'll probably
want to watch it again before season 6
starts up and I'll be covering other
great TV series between now and then
thanks for watching and special thanks
to all of you who supported my channel
and watch better call Saul season 5 with
me I'll talk to you soon